[Music]
Maui now a disaster Zone this Thursday
night this was a home an inferno devours
a tourist town the heartbreaking losses
we are grieving with each other as
people rush to escape
a blueprint to get greener and cleaner
Canada's plan for a net zero power grid
the praise this is a huge step forward
the pushback the draft regulations are
unconstitutional and what it could mean
for your bottom line
the first Home Savings Account we
reality check the program supposed to
help potential homeowners
and Mission To The Moon what Canadian
astronaut Jeremy Hansen is looking
forward to learning plus his take on
UFOs
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight para Nasser oh my gosh
the idyllic island of Maui and Hawaii is
now A Wasteland a major Wildfire wiped
out much of the historic town of Lahaina
off the map The Inferno sparked on
Tuesday fueled by dry conditions and
hurricane winds a trail of heartbreak
and ruin left behind
good evening to you and thanks for
joining us high-end Maui hotels
obliterated Hawaiians homes and
neighborhoods now a disaster Zone at
least 53 people have died from wildfires
that have decimated the popular tourist
destination search and rescue missions
are underway thousands including
Canadians had to scramble to safety when
the Flames erupted Jackson proska
reports on the aftermath
There is almost nothing left of historic
Lahaina
the popular tourist town once the
capital of the Kingdom of Hawaii is all
but gone this is not even the worst of
it
still get dead bodies
in the water floating and on the sea
wall they've been sitting there since
last night
the fire swept through in just minutes
anybody still out here it's time to go
burning all the way to the ocean
Alan Dakar recorded these final moments
outside his store that fire was raging
out of control grab some people who
didn't have a way out
told them get their stuff get in my
truck and we headed out there's a
desperate search underway for survivors
and victims many evacuees are only now
learning they've lost everything woke up
this morning and got on our phones to
pictures of our house
uh just down to them
slap Nothing But Smoke multiple fires
have been burning out of control since
Tuesday
searing the dry brush and everything in
their path hundreds of people are
homeless thousands have no power and no
way to communicate we are grieving with
each other during this inconsolable time
at Maui's main airport there are long
lines for flights off the island
in Vancouver the first Canadians
returned home with harrowing stories of
escape the police came like there were
sirens and they told everyone to
evacuate it's hard to like begin even
processing it right now I'm just
thinking about how like every single
picture I took there was like all burnt
down like it's of all like places that
don't exist the fires are getting closer
and closer to our hotel room and we had
no communication little food all
non-essential travel to Maui is
discouraged fairy flights are bringing
people home so relieved
relieved
people in Maui and the places that we
were in were beautiful places that are
now gone with recovery still underway
it's too soon to talk rebuilding look at
the harbor the fires made history and
destroyed it leaving Maui forever scar
oh my God Jackson prosco Global News
just look joining me on the ground is
NBC correspondent Dana Griffin Dana
you're outside one of the largest
evacuation centers in Maui what are you
hearing from people who've lost
everything in the past 48 hours
hi pharah it's about 11 30 a.m local
time so we're seeing a lot more people
wake up show up coming here to get food
shelter about three to four hundred
people slept here last night and just
some of the stories are remarkable heard
from a couple who had to walk 15 miles
from their home to safety they learned
this morning that their home is no
longer there a neighbor managed to text
them we're hearing other stories of how
people had to escape and solve wall of
flames sitting on top of the Haida which
is just devastated right now it's in
ruins the word we're hearing a lot is
apocalyptic people concerned about what
natural resources what historical
landmarks businesses homes still remain
it's unclear when residents will be
allowed to get back to that neighborhood
before a lot of them will have no home
to go to we learned moments ago from the
Maui fire department that they have
contained the fire they say it's about
eighty percent contained now that means
the fire is not out but it is very
significant and a very much needed
Improvement considering their efforts
were hampered Yesterday by those very
strong wind gusts and we have felt some
of those gusts here today but the winds
have died down significantly which
hopefully will date them in their fight
and again residents here trying to put
the pieces together one surprising thing
I've noticed a lot of people we've
talked to while they're heartbroken to
understand it's a sense of optimism and
gratitude that they made it out alive
and again they were still circles this
ain't standards Edge tonight Cora
Dana Griffin in Maui thank you for that
and as you heard from Jackson earlier
the way the disaster unfolded it was
rapid and it was fueled by harsh winds
on Tuesday afternoon a category 4
hurricane passing 1200 kilometers to the
south of Hawaii caused wind gusts
approaching 100 kilometers per hour to
race down the hillside across Maui now
combined with drought conditions it was
a terrible recipe for a firestorm these
before and after images of lahainas
formally picturesque Waterfront now
reduced to ashes entire neighborhoods
are now gone
Ottawa has unveiled its proposed
regulations designed to bring Canada's
electricity grid to Net Zero by 2035.
that these regulations have been
carefully designed following intense
consultations to maximize the reduction
of carbon pollution while still
providing a reliable affordable grid
provinces and territories have 75 days
to comment on the rules many
environmental groups are applauding the
plan but as tariya isri reports there
are still questions about the use of
natural gas and how much the changes
will cost
Canada is embarking on an electric
future and there's finally a road map
for how to get there this is the spark
to get us to NetZero the federal
government unveiled a long-awaited
blueprint for a net zero power grid if
future where energy is clean affordable
and reliable a future where we can
generate good jobs without creating
greenhouse gas pollution the country's
electrical system
step forward we've been working for over
a decade to see governments properly
Center clean electricity the proposed
changes would cut an estimated 3 340
megatons of greenhouse gas pollution
over the next 25 years that's equivalent
to taking more than a hundred million
Vehicles off the road
but Ottawa is making some exceptions for
communities that rely on non-renewable
energy like diesel we are disappointed
to see some allowances for natural gas
on the grid in the year 2035 and even
beyond the federal government insists it
needs to be flexible as it launches an
electric Revolution but economists say
it won't come cheap nobody should try to
sugarcoat this I think there's a
legitimately open question about whether
our energy bills come down in the future
or go up upgrading the power grid across
the country will cost an estimated 400
billion dollars
government is pledging 40 billion
dollars in financial incentives to help
cover the costs
environmentalists say it will pay off
and Canadians will spend less money on
energy in the long run the ball is
really in the court of provinces to do
what they need to do to embrace this
electric future the final regulations
will be unveiled next year but won't
come into effect until 2035. it's
unlikely any of the targets will be
reached unless the provinces get on
board
Taria esri Global News Ottawa
the proposed changes are already getting
pushed back from two of Canada's largest
oil producing provinces the premiers of
Alberta and Saskatchewan argue
electricity regulation isn't up to the
federal government and have already
refused to implement the regulations
Heather York's West explains the
backlash and the concerns this could
become a battle for jurisdiction
in a province where fortunes are tied to
oil and gas and new wind and solar
projects have been put on a seven-month
hold
ottawa's planned to clean the
electricity grid is not sitting well the
draft regulations are unconstitutional
irresponsible unrealistic and would make
life less affordable for albertans and
Canadians they will not be implemented
in our Province period Saskatchewan's
Premier also says his Province will not
comply we will not ask our residents to
pay the extraordinary price for the
federal government's divisive policies
Scott most said over social media nor
will we risk the Integrity of our
provincial power grid to defy the laws
of thermodynamics I mean I'd like to see
their numbers I'd like to see where what
is it that they're assuming I think
they're right to say it's a heavy lift I
don't know that they're right to say
it's impossible the Federal Regulations
don't go as far as some in the industry
feared after 2035 the use of oil and gas
will be more regulated but the grid will
not be fossil fuel free
still the Canadian Association of
petroleum producers expressed
disappointment that natural gas won't
play a larger role in future power
production fearing the policy will keep
investors away the scale of the energy
transition is so large that we need all
forms of energy including oil including
natural gas it's the emissions we don't
want when it comes seeing the
electricity
Alberta and Saskatchewan have the
longest way to go unlike provinces with
well-established Hydro or nuclear
networks natural gas and coal currently
account for more than 80 percent of
Alberta's and saskatchans electricity a
daunting transition the Prairie
Provinces say they aren't willing to
tackle by 2035. Heather urac's West
Global News Calgary
it's desperate times if you're in the
market for a home of your own prices are
through the roof and residential
building construction has slowed in
recent months now we know that 22
million homes are needed by 2030 to help
with Canada's huge housing affordability
crisis but new data from statistics
Canada shows the number of residential
building permits across the country is
actually down in four provinces
including Ontario and one territory
while the supply issue is going to take
some time to solve the liberal
government says a new savings account
for first-time home buyers is helping
people get into the market Mackenzie
gray reports
nice to see you and thanks for your work
it's her signature policy to a major
political problem Christian Freeland
selling a first home savings account and
I'm really aware that zinc is
huge huge huge challenge to put it
mildly so how does it work potential new
homeowners can deposit up to eight grand
a year in a new account and get tax
deductions like an rrsp contribution but
when they withdraw the cash to buy their
first home it's tax-free just like a
tfsa I think the program is a great
program it's really going to help
Canadians to get a bigger down payment
to save for the purchase of a first home
eligible applicants can deposit up to 40
Grand a year over the lifetime of the
account but opening one can be a
challenge despite being able to offer
them since April TD CIBC and
Scotiabank still don't have the accounts
available RBC and National the only two
major institutions that do it would be
great to see it to see this first Home
Savings Account more readily available
across the country even if it is
available it would only make a small
Denton sky-high house prices the eight
grand representing only 1.1 percent of
the cost of an average property and only
five percent of an average 20 down
payment money that would likely increase
demand without addressing housing Supply
these kind of demand supportive measures
really don't end up helping
affordability because they just put
further upward pressure on on home
prices affordability likely continued to
be elusive with the Canadian housing and
mortgage Corporation projecting Canada
will be short 3.5 million homes by 2030
adding that drastic transformation is
needed from governments a partial
solution gaining steam amongst academic
and Banks reducing immigration to
pre-pandemic levels after the Bank of
Canada recently said the 1.8 million
permanent residents temporary foreign
workers and international students who
entered Canada in 2022 have helped keep
house prices High we are trying to do
immigration policy first and hoping that
housing policy will work its way out
don't expect a change from the Liberals
on immigration new housing Minister Sean
Frazier has said his focus is on
building new homes and conservative
leader Pierre pauliev his sidestep
questions pharah and whether he'd keep
the liberal plan
Mackenzie gray in Ottawa thank you
Mackenzie
a deadly weather system coming up the
tropical storm slamming South Korea
[Music]
intense winds and rain pummeled South
Korea as tropical storm canoe made
landfall a day after wreaking havoc in
Japan at least one person's drowned in
the flooding forecasters had warned part
of the country could see up to 50
centimeters of rain 14 000 people have
been forced to leave their homes the
storm is moving toward North Korea
and a shocking political development in
Ecuador a presidential candidate was
assassinated during a campaign event and
a warning this footage is disturbing you
will hear gunshots and then we're
freezing the video
this appears to be the moment shots were
fired at Fernando via vicencio nine
others were injured Ecuador's outgoing
president declared a national state of
emergency following the assassination
calling it a political crime and an
attempt to sabotage the electoral
process via vicencio was a vocal critic
of corruption and organized crime
ecuadorians say the murder reflects a
rising wave of insecurity in the country
Ecuador's election is still scheduled
for August 20th
[Music]
cash cut off ahead why the World Bank
isn't lending money to Uganda
an emergency Summit is underway in
Nigeria as the 15-member economic
community of West African States discuss
how to restore democracy after last
month's coup in Niger
the chairman of the group says the
military-backed Takeover poses a threat
to the entire region niger's military
Junta defied the August 6 deadline to
reinstate the democratically elected
president they have so far not engaged
in any meaningful talks with the block
which today ordered the activation of a
standby military force for possible use
against the junta the World Bank is
halted new lending to Uganda saying the
country's harsh
anti-lgbtq2 plus laws violate its values
uganda's president remains defiant today
vowing to find alternative sources of
credit saying he's focused on reducing
borrowing and will not bow to
International pressure same-sex
relationships were already illegal in
Uganda the new law signed in May added
the death penalty for same-sex
transmission of HIV deliberate or not
and for aggravated homosexuality
next I speak with Jeremy Hansen about
the challenges of preparing to go to the
Moon
[Music]
three two one release release
virgin galactic's VSS Unity released
from its Mothership this morning
carrying its first tourist to space
during the brief flight the trio of
tourists got to experience a few minutes
of weightlessness before landing
Canadian astronaut Jeremy Hansen will
also be taken to the skies next fall
Hanson and his Artemis two colleagues
got their first look this week at the
Orion spacecraft that will orbit the
earth twice and then carry them around
the Moon before rocketing them back home
and we are so pleased to have Canadian
astronaut Jeremy Hansen joining us now
from Houston such an honor and pleasure
to speak with you thanks for being with
us
it's my pleasure for
so let me ask you first I mean you saw
the ship as you call it for the very
first time what was that like for you I
mean you've dreamed about being an
astronaut for a long time that moment
took us there
pretty special moment for myself and and
my crew
um you know it just gets very real for
you we've been we've been in mock-ups of
this um capsule many times we know where
stuff is supposed to be and kind of what
it's supposed to look like it's
simulated in Houston for us but
traveling to Florida and seeing the
actual one that they're working on it's
not quite finished there's still lots of
work to be done but uh to see the real
Hardware see how pristine it is
um was just really kind of magical for
us to look inside when we leave Earth
we will set a course such that eight
days later we will come back and hit the
earth and land in the Pacific Ocean
that's like it's like threading a needle
from here to the Moon away and it's
really really difficult and really
really important because if you get it
wrong you die this Mission will tell us
more about human life on Mars and and
what what are you looking for in that
and what do you think we're going to
learn from it yeah I think what's
important to understand is that what
we're doing when we lay out our return
Journey To The Moon over the course of
many many Artemis missions we're we're
charting a course to Mars we're thinking
about okay what are the pieces we're
missing to get to Mars what do we have
to learn that we can learn on the moon
that is only you know three days away
essentially uh before we actually go to
Mars and that's sort of what it's what
it's all about let's talk about that
Adventure I know I know your focus right
now is not uh Mars it's your it's your
mission the mission ahead of you but if
you were asked to go to Mars would you
go yeah I'd have to I'd have to have
another chat with the family to see if
uh if that got approved but I I would
like in in here in this heart I would I
want to say yes I'm very much interested
in a round-trip commission uh to Mars um
and just be a magical place to visit
it's so mysterious out there um and and
you you're a fighter pilot I mean would
you give us some some of your thoughts
on UFOs and UFO testimony that we've
heard you know I can only relate my
story as a fighter pilot I can't even
fighter pilot I I spent many a night
sleeping in a hangar beside an armed
aircraft waiting for the alarm to go off
to scramble to go intercept whatever
needed to be intercept and and I had
kind of secretly hoped you know I was a
big fan of the X-Files if people know
what that is um you know I wanted to
believe
um and I secretly hope that someday I
would see evidence from you know another
planet visiting Earth I never did there
are no
um you know no secret briefings that
these things exist I think the fact that
we see things in the sky those things
are real
um I don't think there's any doubt about
that and they are unidentified and we
don't know what the sources of them are
um but they're not in my opinion
extraterrestrial I don't think that
evidence exists at least I haven't seen
it yet as much as I would like to
believe but it is worth trying to figure
out you know where are these coming from
who are the entities that are creating
them and flying them around different
parts of the world I think there's a lot
to be looked into there astronaut Jeremy
Hansen thanks so much for being generous
with your time and joining us on global
national yeah it's my pleasure I'm so
proud of Canada right now I think it's
just really highlighting the genius in
our country that we have been invited to
go on this Mission back to the moon the
first time in over 50 years the reason
I'm on this mission is very little to do
with me I had to do my part but the
reality is it has to do with thousands
of Canadians who who bought into a goal
a vision of Doing Great Things by
collaborating and now their genius is
being recognized and it's being asked
from our International Partners to to
for us to contribute that genius and I
think it reflects really well in Canada
well we're so proud that you're
representing us thank you again my
pleasure have a great day
that's global national for this Thursday
night I'm Farah Nasser thank you for
spending part of your evening with us
and tonight's your Canada is Kootenai
lake near caslow British Columbia
until tomorrow take care of yourselves
and take care of each other good night
[Music]